merci d'être avec nous Jean-François
lapin et nous accompagner pendant cette
première demi-heure sénateur les
républicains du Pas-de-Calais président
de la commission des affaires
européennes ici au Sénat on va bien sûr
parler de la réforme des retraites mais
d'abord on l'a vu dans le journal ces
images du séisme qui a frappé la Turquie
et le nord de la Syrie plus de 8000
morts qui sont déjà à déplorer l'Union
européenne à mobiliser en Turquie 1185
secouristes auprès de 19 États membres
dont la France et l'Allemagne et en
Syrie elle finance des opérations de ce
cours est-ce que la solidarité
européenne est à la hauteur de ce drame
dans l'immédiat bien sûr parce que il y
a une situation d'urgence et je suis
très heureux qu'on puisse en parler
d'emblée parce que je trouve que depuis
48 72 heures dans les médias et vous le
voyez c'est le troisième sujet qu'on
exprime là dans votre information
presque 8000 morts déjà annoncés et
probablement bien plus donc dans la
hiérarchie des normes de l'information
c'est quand même un sujet terrible c'est
un sujet terrible pour plusieurs raisons
parce que en plus on va dans des terres
où la situation en ce moment
politiquement et difficile
ne serait-ce que à l'interne mais aussi
dans la relation avec la communauté
internationale et je pense que le fait
que la solidarité prime avant tout sur
la vie humaine et vraiment un enjeu très
fort et moi j'aspire à ce que les États
soient aujourd'hui très attentifs à
l'aide qu'ils vont apporter sur sur son
dimensionnement par rapport au seisme
dont on n'a pas encore vu tous les aléas
ça veut dire que de ce drame peut naître
un resserrement des liens entre l'Union
européenne et la Turquie je ne sais pas
si ça ira jusque là mais en tout cas le
premier objectif c'est tenter de sauver
encore des vies avec des moyens à la
hauteur et d'ailleurs je salue les
secourisme parce que on sait très bien
que la situation sismique n'est pas
encore stabilisée donc ça veut dire que
chaque geste chaque moment de ces
sauvetages est un risque pour ceux qui
pour ceux qui vont parler de la réforme
des retraites
de l'actualité en France 750 000
manifestants hier selon le ministère de
l'Intérieur
des millions selon la CGT est-ce que le
gouvernement peut rester sans bouger
face à ces centaines de milliers de
Français qui ont défilé à nouveau dans
les rues de frontières oui c'est vrai
qu'il y a encore beaucoup de monde qui
défilent et c'est la preuve que c'est
une réforme qui touche les gens avant
tout
et même si certains
prennent simplement comme totem
l'age de départ légal on sent très bien
que ça touche les gens sur plein de
sujets sur la pénibilité sur la retraite
des dames sur la retraite des dames et
je pense que c'est important de s'y
arrêter en ce qui me concerne l'âge de
départ je ne renierai jamais les
amendements qu'on apportait ici au Sénat
notamment pour allonger le temps de
travail la dure la durée de temps de
travail en tout cas dans sa limite d'âge
parce qu'on sait très bien
qu'aujourd'hui
on est à 1,7 actif pour pour retraité
que la situation n'est pas dans
l'instant pour s'arranger et que nous
devrons prendre des mesures mais
néanmoins moi sur le fond du texte mais
un petit mot sur les mobilisations parce
que Philippe Martinez le secrétaire
général de la CGT vous ne vous l'avez
entendu dans le journal il dit que si
les gouvernements ne bougent pas les
mouvements seront plus durs il y aura
des grèves reconductibles des blocages
vous comprenez cette position
une position de syndicaliste qui doit
porter son message je pense qu'il ne va
pas renier le message qu'il a porté
d'entrée c'est-à-dire voilà pour eux le
totem c'est l'âge légal donc à partir de
là on reste là la question c'est de
savoir comment les syndicats ont pu
discuter avec le gouvernement sur cette
question moi je suis très très attaché à
ça de savoir comment
l'avant c'est fait avant de porter le
texte attention
on a considéré que de moi de discussion
suffisait une visite dans le bureau de
la première ministre et puis avec le
ministre du Travail aurait suffi mais je
pense qu'il fallait aller plus loin
parce que
ce n'est pas au travers simplement un
projet de loi de finances rectificatif
qu'on peut remettre en cause tout un
système à la fois pour l'existant mais
aussi pour le futur donc je crois que
que là voilà et puis un deuxième sujet
il y a un deuxième sujet sur la
mobilisation c'est que je pense que le
timing alors on me dit toujours oui mais
toute façon c'est une réforme à
populaire quel que soit le moment ça
n'ira pas mais là sur le timing
franchement il est choisi de manière
machiavélique on est dans une situation
où chaque Français et c'est pour ça que
je le disais que ça touche tous les
Français les Français vont à la pompe à
essence ils payent le plein
quasi deux fois plus cher quasi deux
fois plus cher que ce qui a et ce qui
avait il y a un an et demi ils vont
faire leurs caddie de course ils le paye
30 % plus cher donc vous vous rendez
compte on est dans une situation où les
gens s'appauvrissent et on leur dit vous
allez encore faire un effort parce que
ça va pas moi je pense que
d'attendre que les prix
l'inflation régresse on a des
économistes avertis qui nous annoncent
que
mars avril ça devrait peut-être aller un
petit peu mieux en tout cas pas la
panacée mais que après voilà et donc on
était pas à 3 mois près regardez la
réforme des retraites elle était prévue
dans le mandat précédent d'Emmanuel
Macron elle a été arrêtée pour la cause
de du de la covid par reprise et là on
la reprend dans une situation qui est
peut-être plus dégradée encore que celle
que celle d'avant donc moi je je crois
fortement que quand on veut pas faire
passer une réforme impopulaire mais on
sait qu'elle est impopulaire qu'elle est
nécessaire mais un populaire on doit
être attentif au moment où la fait pas
sur le fond de ce texte parce que il y a
un peu de camp dans votre partie à ceux
qui disent que le gouvernement a déjà
fait des compromis et que le texte
présenté s'aligne sur le texte des
républicains et puis il y a ceux qui
disent que ça ne va pas assez loin qu'il
faut encore faire des améliorations
notamment sur la carrière donc de quel
côté vous êtes vous est-ce que vous
voterez ce texte là où est-ce
est-ce que vous voterez le texte en
l'état moi je vous dis non d'abord je ne
vends pas mon vote avant le débat
parlementaire je trouve que on a été un
peu vite en besogne sortie du bureau de
la première ministre les uns et les
autres disent très bien on votera ce
texte on vous dites
nous installons des républicains et je
trouve que finalement cette négociation
qui a pu y avoir elle ne semblait pas si
bonne que ça puisque à chaque jour
suffit sa peine et à chaque jour on voit
une amélioration nécessaire à apporter
au texte donc ça veut dire que je pense
que le packaging qui avait été proposé
par la première ministre à nos instances
des républicains
a été fait un petit peu rapidement et je
pense que moi je souhaite attendre
il a peut-être pas été assez ferme mais
surtout je pense qu'on devait attendre
le débat parlementaire moi quel texte va
nous arriver de l'Assemblée nationale au
Sénat qu'est-ce qu'on va devoir modifier
pour redonner un peu de de vigueur
aztexte et je le redis sans renier pour
ma part les différents amendements que
j'ai déjà qu'on a déjà cossigné sur le
sujet donc moi je suis sur une ligne où
je comprends qu'il faut une réforme ou
je dis qu'il faut une réforme où je
comprends que l'âge légal de départ doit
être un peu allongé vous savez quand on
a mis à 60 ans la retraite quand
François Mitterrand a mis à 60 ans l'âge
de l'âge de légal de départ il y avait
trois actifs pour pour un retraité donc
c'était la panacée mais c'était ça a été
une véritable connerie aujourd'hui je
compare ça à l'abandon du nucléaire en
France c'est à dire que on paye
aujourd'hui des stratégies qui à ont été
ont été mal appliqués ou en tout cas qui
n'ont pas anticipé l'avenir mais pour
vous il faut quand même reporter sa
tâche de départ ou est-ce que vous dites
comment réunir par exemple que pour les
Français qui ont commencé à travailler
tôt l'âge de départ ne doit pas compter
c'est le nom de la nuités qui doit être
pris en compte le nombre d'annuités bien
sûr mais toute façon quand on fait les
calculs on revient très très souvent à
43 ans il y a très peu très peu de
très peu de moments où on se rend compte
moi je suis très attentif c'est à la
situation des femmes la situation des
dames une avancée sociale à mon avis
importante avait été faite quand on
accorde aujourd'hui 8 trimestres
valorisés aux dames 4 4 avec des points
et 4 4 dans la temporalité
7 si on si on propose donc un âge légal
de départ à 64 ans finalement cet
avantage qui était important pour les
dames qui ont élevé leurs enfants il est
perdu il est perdu parce que on repousse
de deux ans j'ai fait quelques
simulations sur des membres de ma
famille et effectivement on va leur
demander de travailler plus et
finalement de perdre cet avantage voilà
et je pense que là-dessus on doit être
très attentif c'est la politique c'est
de la politique de la famille qui va
aussi parce que c'est important et je
pense aussi que les les mamans les
anciennes mamans jeunes qui partiraient
elles peuvent aussi quelquefois et dans
la plupart des cas s'occuper de leurs
petits-enfants
les sénateurs de votre groupe les
sénateurs les républicains on va
l'écouter à la sortie au micro de
Mathias Arès
je dénonce toutes les attitudes qui sont
contraires à l'unité au rassemblement de
notre famille politique nous sommes dans
un moment difficile difficile pour pour
les Français et cela nécessite de de
mesurer chaque fois ces points de vue
c'est prise de parole
la réforme est difficile mais c'est la
réforme Gérard Larcher nous l'a rappelé
ce matin aussi qui nécessite du du
courage
on imagine qu'il pense à rien mais
est-ce que c'est un message qui
s'adresse aussi à Xavier Bertrand donc
vous êtes proche il y a un manque de
courage
fait partie des gens qui connaissent
très bien sujet il a été ministre de la
question
n'a pas été ferme qu'il faut aller plus
loin que l'une votera pas le texte dans
l'été sur cette position en disant que
je pense que le l'engagement qui a été
pris à la sortie du bureau de la
première ministre était un peu trop
anticipé et qu'il fallait laisser faire
le débat parlementaire c'est mon point
de vue et je ne pense pas être disruptif
par rapport à ce que pense ma famille
politique l'Union ça ne se décrète pas
l'Union ça se fait ça se produit ça ça
c'est l'union en action mais là en
l'occurrence je pense qu'on a été un
petit peu vite on va parler de
l'actualité au Sénart puisque hier près
d'un an après le début de la guerre en
Ukraine le Sénat voté à la quasi-animité
un texte pour affirmer son soutien au
pays on va faire le point avec notre
journaliste parlementaire Audrey
[Musique]
bonjour Audrey bonjour bonjour et Audrey
le Sénat examiné donc hier une
proposition de résolution pour exprimer
son soutien l'Ukraine condamné la guerre
d'agression menée par la Russie et
appelé renforcement de l'aide fournie à
l'Ukraine proposition adoptée oui à 324
voix pour et 16 voix contre je vais y
revenir mais d'abord un petit peu de
contexte cette proposition de résolution
à l'initiative du président des
indépendants Claude malurey intervient
une semaine après la visite du président
de la Rada le Parlement
ukrainien au Sénat face au sénateur
justement il a eu des mots très forts
dont cette phrase rappelée par Patrick
canner hier on nous tue par le froid et
l'obscurité des mots qui évidemment ont
touché au Sénat et pour renforcer
l'aspect solennel de cette proposition
c'est Gérard Larcher le président qui
l'a inscrit à l'ordre du jour alors
Claude Malhuret aurait aimé une
unanimité d'autant que le texte était
soutenu par le gouvernement mais le
groupe communiste en a décidé autrement
parmi les points d'achauffement la
crainte d'une escalade qui entraînerait
la France dans un conflit mondial
écouter d'abord l'intervention de Claude
malurer pour défendre ce point du texte
suivi de celle de Pierre Laurent le
patron des communistes qui explique que
son groupe ne votera pas
les réalistes se crainent l'escalade ils
pensent qu'il y a des lignes rouges à ne
pas franchir chaque épisode de cette
guerre prouve qu'ils ont tort en
refusant l'escalade ils en laissent le
monopole à Poutine et font perdre à
chaque fois les semaines nécessaires à
la contre-offensive c'est semaine c'est
moi parfois ce sont des milliers du
crânien qui meurent nous ne voterons pas
la résolution qui nous est proposée elle
énonce des rappels de principes que nous
défendons nous-mêmes face à l'agression
criminelle de la Russie mais elle ne
propose face à ce drame qu'un seul
chemin de fête l'escalade militaire
clairement revendiquée par l'auteur de
cette proposition de résolution Claude
malurey et surtout elle fait l'impasse
sur tout appel à une initiative de
négociation et de paix ce n'est pas un
oubli c'est un choix celui de la guerre
comme seul chemin possible oubliant la
leçon de tous les conflits récents
le groupe communiste qui n'a donc pas
voté cette proposition vous comprenez la
position du groupe et du coup c'est une
position
un peu à l'écart de ce que l'on pense
tous ici au Sénat la proposition de
résolution elle a été déposée comme vous
l'avez dit dans un compromis dans un
consensus de la Conférence des
Présidents le président malgré accepté
que elle soit portée par par le Sénat
maintenant les arguments de l'escalade
moi je suis toujours un petit peu
circonspect quand j'entends ça si le 24
février 2022 qui déclenche l'escalade
qui montre la première marche de
l'escalade ce sont les Russes en
débarquant 600 commandos qui débarquent
akiev et qui entame une forme de guerre
pensant que ils vont avoir
d'emblée sous leurs ordres l'Ukraine qui
a résisté donc je crois qu'il faut
voilà il faut il faut faire attention
aux mots il faut peser les si
effectivement on ne veut pas d'escalade
maintenant il y a une décision du groupe
communisme moi je la respecte à les
démocratiques c'est c'est un peu dommage
de ne pas avoir l'unanimité du Sénat sur
un sujet sur un sujet si important dans
le détail certains de vos collègues les
républicains comme à l'ingénier se sont
abstenus comment vous vous interprétez
ça ce sont des positions isolées ce sont
des positions isolées voilà
la question de l'aide apporté à
l'Ukraine était aussi au cœur des débat
hier oui parce que c'est aussi l'un des
objets du texte renforcer l'aide à
l'Ukraine pour Guillaume Gontard le
président des écologistes c'est oui pour
envoyer des chars Leclerc oui aussi pour
envoyer des avions de combat une
question épineuse qui anime le débat
actuellement écoutez-le
nous demandons solennellement au
président de la République de livrer que
Charles à l'Ukraine au-delà de son
efficacité militaire que nous savons
limitée cette décision est indispensable
politiquement ayant constaté le grand
sang froid dans son preuve le pouvoir
politique et l'état-major ukrainien nous
croyons possibles de fournir
collectivement des chasseurs à l'Ukraine
sans risquer de les voir utiliser à
d'autres fins que la défense de son
territoire toujours sur la question de
l'armement le ministre des Français de
l'étranger qui représentait hier le
gouvernement au Sénat en a profité pour
lister l'aide envoyée par la France à
l'Ukraine est direct aide européenne
aussi écoutée
nous allons poursuivre notre soutien
dans le domaine entier aérien
fournitures d'une batterie asmt
conjointement avec l'Italie d'un radar
GM20 et de missiles pour les batteries
entièresiennes crottes
essentiel pour protéger la population
civile ukrainienne des frappes russes
nous travaillons également à des
solutions pour fournir à l'Ukraine des
munitions de nouveaux véhicules blindés
du carburant et pour assurer le maintien
en conditions opérationnelles des
équipements livrés et assurer un
ravitaillement en carburant
alors j'ai vraiment réduit parce qu'il y
avait une très longue liste de tout ce
que la France envoie et notamment la
participation de la France à la facilité
européenne pour la paix mais d'abord je
vais revenir sur ce qu'a dit Guillaume
Gontard est-ce qu'il faut envoyer des
avions de combat on a bien entendu le
message du président Stéphane chouc la
semaine dernière quand il utilise ce mot
très symbolique le président du
parlement ukrainien très symbolique sur
les envoyer nous les ailes de la liberté
je pense que c'est voilà c'est c'est
très symbolique je le garde est-ce que
je suis d'accord avec ça je pense qu'à
notre niveau parlementaire
se positionner ainsi vous aurez un tas
d'avis différents et quelquefois de gens
qui connaissent pas du tout la situation
sur sur place je pense que les propos
équilibrés du ministre sont très
intéressants parce que finalement
Guillaume Gontard dit quoi en voyant des
avions pour que les Ukrainiens protègent
leur sol un avion de chasse aujourd'hui
c'est fait à la fois pour protéger son
sol mais c'est aussi fait pour traverser
les il est hors de question bien sûr
dans ce conflit d'imaginer que l'Union
européenne en tout cas les États membres
de l'Union européenne qui apportent de
l'aide à l'Ukraine ne souhaite qu'elle
attaque la Russie c'est pas l'objet
l'objet c'est de se défendre et
aujourd'hui avec les missiles solaires
et les technologies de toutes les pays
de l'Union et même des Américains on est
capable d'assurer un bouclier
défensif important sur l'Ukraine donc
pour l'instant restons à l'étape et à la
réflexion sur le bouclier anti-aérien en
cas d'attaque russe par les airs les
avions c'est vraiment à l'échelle
diplomatique et là je ne sais pas si ça
relève même de notre propre compétence
interne sur l'action de l'Union
européenne un dixième paquet de
sanctions est prévu pour le 24 février
le Trice anniversaire de l'agression de
la Russie en Ukraine avec notamment un
plafonnement des prix du pétrole est-ce
que l'Union européenne en fait assez oui
elle y va progressivement l'Union
européenne donc voilà sans risquer de
mettre à mal sa propre économie donc il
y a aussi là un équilibre à trouver mais
je pense qui qui a été qui a été activé
durant la présidente française et qui
par étape progresse et je pense que
c'est c'est intéressant d'aller dans ce
sens et de continuer donc l'Union
européenne en fait elle assez je dis que
pour l'instant elle fait ce qu'il faut
et peut-être est-ce que ça fonctionne
parce que c'est vrai qu'on se dit
dixième paquet de sanctions en fait
à chaque jour il faut remettre le métier
sur l'ouvrage sur le métier et je crois
que voilà c'est une situation qui est
évolutive et elle progressera merci
Audrey merci à tout à l'heure dans le
club oui on va parler réforme des
retraites pour changer
merci beaucoup à tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui il y a une discussion en
séance Jean-François Rapin sur la
proposition de résolution européenne que
vous présentez avec François noelbucher
le président de la commission des lois
sur l'avenir de l'Agence européenne de
garde frontière et de garde de côte
Frontex dont la mission c'est de
surveiller les frontières extérieures de
l'Union européenne il y a eu 330 000
entrées irrégulières qui ont été
enregistrées en 2022 + 64% par rapport à
2021 est-ce que fontex est un outil
efficace oui c'est un outil efficace qui
est la plus grande agence aujourd'hui
l'Union européenne en terme de en termes
de budget en termes de personnel elle
doit encore progresser pour s'adapter à
une situation qui devient vraiment
presque incontrôlable
mais Frontex sort d'une crise une crise
à la fois humaine une crise de vocation
ou une crise de de fonctionnement
et c'est pour ça que nous avons souhaité
avec François Noël buffet porter cette
cette proposition de résolution pour
réaccorder tout d'abord notre confiance
affrontex moi je les ai vu travailler je
suis allé en Slovaquie je suis allé en
Pologne en bordure de frontière où on
voit où on voit les les agents de
Frontex en pleine action et d'ailleurs
en action coordonnée à la fois avec les
autorités locales mais aussi avec toutes
les autres agences européennes donc la
question de confiance il faut pouvoir la
régler un nouveau directeur a été a été
nommé mais c'est surtout dans les
missions de Frontex Frontex est une
agence de garde de frontières
ça n'est pas une agence de de
surveillance et de surveillance du
respect des droits fondamentaux il y a
des agences qui existent pour ça et
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on veut
peut-être donner à fond à affrontex une
image qui est plus orienter vers d'abord
les droits fondamentaux qui sont
essentiels et on le rappelle dans la PME
je veux dire qu'on on n'est pas muet sur
la question mais en tout cas on pense
aussi Frontex doit venir vraiment en
appui des des des agents locaux et des
agents des États membres pour pour
surveiller les frontières extérieures on
va continuer à parler de ces questions
d'immigration dans votre région on va
aller dans les hauts de France à Amiens
on retrouve Jean-Marc chevaucher merci
d'être avec nous Jean-Marc d'accord en
chef adjoint du Courrier Picard et
Jean-Marc on va parler avec vous de ces
communes du littoral qui s'équipent de
caméra de surveillance pour lutter
contre l'immigration clandestine
oui rien ce sont des caméras qui sont
payées par les Britanniques puisque nous
sommes chargés de
des affaires de frontières à leur place
en France alors il y en a quelques-unes
qui ont été installées entre entre la
baie d'otti et la baie de la Baie de
Somme mais un petit peu plus bas jusqu'à
Mers-les-Bains c'est-à-dire tout ce qui
tout ce qui fait les 80 km de littoral
picard alors les avis sont partagés
puisque on sait que en ce qui concerne
ce ce lourd problème d'immigration
illégales personne ne sait vraiment par
quelle boule prendre donc aujourd'hui on
en est là il y a des il y a des caméras
ça permet peut-être de sauver des vies
parce que ça permet peut-être aussi que
des gens d'embarquent pas n'importe
comment dans des conditions désastreuses
dans les conditions météorologiques
désastreuses mais voilà on a on a mis en
place
ce moyen enfin à travers le financement
des autorités britanniques
Jean-Marc une question
Rapin vous connaissez bien ce problème
vous êtes
issus du littoral est-ce que vous pensez
que que voilà alors je le disais
personne ne sait vraiment ce qu'il faut
faire mais est-ce que vous pensez que
c'est une part de la solution
aujourd'hui
Jean-Marc c'est un des
c'est un des moyens qu'on doit
s'accorder les caméras elles sont
positionnées effectivement sur le
littoral dans le cadre d'un programme
qui s'appelle terminus elles vont être
financées justement par
ce qu'on appelle les accords du Touquet
sont les Anglais qui vont le payer vous
l'avez rappelé très justement il va y en
avoir aussi sur le sur le littoral de la
Côte d'Opale à proximité de la
cote-picarde
effectivement pour surveiller les plages
et l'intrusion pour pour traverser la
Manche de migrants mais surtout aussi
pour surveiller les passeurs parce que
les passeurs aujourd'hui des techniques
de passage qui qui défraient la
chronique je dirais et qui et qui pose
des problèmes à nos services de
policiers de gendarmerie et puis vous
savez nous sommes sur un littoral où il
y a quelques ports bien sûr mais il y a
aussi beaucoup de base nautiques ou sont
stockés des bateaux avec des moteurs
avec voilà et depuis cette migratoires
et sans faire de stigmatisation il y a
quelques intrusions avec vol de moteur
quelquefois vols de bateaux et je pense
que c'est important de pouvoir protéger
de pouvoir protéger aussi ses bases
nautiques et la vidéo protection et la
vidéo surveillance est un des outils un
des outils mis en place avec toutes les
forces moi je les vois souvent vrai sur
le territoire ça n'est pas facile
quelquefois dans des conditions
météorologiques comme en ce moment un
peu compliqué et c'est souvent la nuit
et moi je les salue vraiment les forces
de sécurité qui surveillent nos
littoraux Jean-Marc il nous reste 30
secondes vous avez besoin d'une
précision un mot les accords du Touquet
Oriane voilà ce qu'on peut demander à
Jean-François qu'il les connaît bien en
30 secondes les accords du Touquet qui
date qui date d'une période antérieure
non c'est se dire aujourd'hui que les
accords du Touquet eux aussi ont eu une
progression puisque je rappelle les
Emmanuel Macron en 2017 il faut remettre
tout sur la table les accords du Touquet
ça ne correspond plus oui ça ne
correspondait plus ça ne correspondait
plus parce qu'aujourd'hui on parle
d'immigration illégale alors que les
accords du Touquet ont été faits pour la
migration légale donc les accords du
Touquet peuvent rester pour assurer la
migration légale mais je pense que le
dispositif doit être renforcé et là
c'est l'action de l'Union européenne par
rapport à par rapport au Royaume-Uni et
je crois que là il y a le pacte
migratoire européen qui est un chantier
de longue haleine dont on ne voit pas le
bout qui avance à tout petit pas qui
nous apportera je l'espère la solution
merci Jean-Marc chevaucher merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous c'est la
réforme des retraites elle a une du
Courrier Picard moins mobilisée pas des
mobilisé c'est à la Une de votre journal
merci beaucoup merci Jean-François Robin
d'avoir été notre invité dans 20 minutes
dans le club des territoires où on
viendra sur cette mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites on ira notamment
dans le centre Val de Loire et du côté
de Bordeaux et on en parle tout de suite
puisque notre invité c'est le Ministre
Olivier du socle